this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you thank you so much for the kind
introduction and for was importantly for
having me here on this beautiful campus
I if you ever visit texas a man and you
would like to see fall colors you will
never see that not now not later it's
going to be all the same gray is it
vintage fine it's so pretty here I
wished more when they fly back to that
since I will take a picture from the
plane to throw my wife because she
misses for the fall colors I have quite
a bit of slides but the journey to the
slides are simple so I will go through
the past and they are showing a bunch of
different phenotypes and that's the
point of my participation today is to
convince you that there is life beyond
just mana gated just one occasion it's
just one of the acceleration reduced by
the plants and plants produce hundreds
of different and other level species of
silicones and I would like to leave you
with a strong conviction that other
absolutement in plants have a quotient
physiological array of functions in the
worst resort achill processes and
especially in defense against pathogens
and insects and even interaction with
beneficial microorganisms organisms
called colonizing roots so i would like
to show this picture simply because i'm
really proud that texas A&M decided to
build a new building for plant pathology
and microbiology department is going to
be right here so this is my lab my lab
is quite large simply because we do a
lot of freedom in the field and i will
explain you how backwards and so these
are all great your students here kiss
her there's another graduate students
and
all of the gradient ok so I collaborated
with a lot of different planetary of
people in the world I was funded by the
National Science Foundation for ten
years in a row and that funding came to
collaborate with Nancy color if you were
sick wisconsin madison to study
attention a fox lakers a in maize and of
sleep is produced by the fungal pathogen
produce legs i collaborated a lotta
skibo Forstner in at university of
göttingen beds until i went there in
2010 sabbatical leave and i now am
capable of running all the biochemical
analysis that you taught me how to do
while in his lab and now i'm your dreams
that in my life and in fact we do not
I'd not vibrating longer and input I
collaborate is these people but they do
not need the services any longer to run
fight hormone analysis for volatile
organic compounds analysis or out of all
the tools used by the plans I started
collaboration this group here mr. Becker
Nelson and Jenna Coleman and they are
testing our buildings for assistance to
local Connelly flight which is a big
problem here in the north of the United
States but other problem in taxes at all
that's has its own problem in deserts
for Joe's famous in my thoughts and
contamination by by the front way that
hummus I collaborated you struck
candidly if you work some trichoderma
Venus as you may know and the role of
technical appearance trigger no more
games is it at the root colonizing n to
fight that induces induce systemic
in the above ground organs and we just
got funded by USDA to study signaling
events between the two organisms and
clever it is a story and to myself it
was primarily for fuel based testing for
mycotoxin contamination and more
recently I collaborate with rezian st.
Pearson and Beth's to study effect of
pseudomonas fluorescens which also gives
an end to fight of beet and corn that
can do systemic resistance and promotes
growth and fortunately we're not had
time to talk about this research so I
will give it a brief for you of what we
want to do in my lab and what the idea
is behind all of these different
projects that we have in the lab we
primarily work is to gene families sleep
oxygenases and pokes a vital 1808
interfaces and these genes are required
for são paulo just one occasion
biosynthesis but production of other
oxer limits then I will talk you put
focus primarily on what we have found so
far in terms of the role that absolute
mins play in maize interactions views
design which severely reduces
reminiscent and a specialist claims that
produces a fat ass and then it will
finish up Wiz showing you the data the
suggestion to the boxes units and
oxalate things that are expressing
eludes have a strong where are the
positive or negative role in the
interaction you started erm appearance
and conferring in you systemic
resistance in above-ground audience
that's also a new project so what are
also lateness of solutions simply stand
for oxygenated lipids that are implants
derived from to polyunsaturated fatty
acids we delay it contains two double
bonds 82 with elana case contains three
double bonds to the tribute speech in
safe
the resulting products of this primary
oxygenation of variances is production
of a vast array of oxidants not sure
this scheme or biosynthesis of his
machinations and they are suspected in
addition to just Monica severe suspected
was as potent signaling tivities strong
antimicrobial and insecticidal
activities however we know very little
to put small kids are doing in the
plants we know what they do in animal
systems let me show you will they do in
any system this is an inspiration for my
lab so I show only here there is several
reviews you will never find a review
that will show you what oxa lipids to in
mammalian system simply because they
don't even call them usually obsolete as
they call them by the class of hormones
and so one of these classes of moments
is called prostaglandins there are six
other large groups of hormones play the
toxins from books and so on that are
produced by the melon systems I will
only show you an example for prospect
rankings because this molecules are
diverse again in use a reduced from
arachidonic acid which has 20 carbon
chain fatty acids that has four double
bonds they produced a subset of
prostaglandins all of these letters and
numbers indicate a different molecular
species of this prostaglandins and each
of this prospect landings is produced
specifically in specific cells and
transported to a specific servants
quarters and perceived in other
different cells by a number of different
g-protein coupled receptors so if you
think about this morning case just one
in case it as a single to center in land
both Corey one dose and duration so
prostaglandins different molecular
species of prostaglandins and melon
systems have different g-protein coupled
receptors and different functions that
they convey and if you look at the list
of all the different physiological
processes across the grandest regulate
it's amazing they seem to regulate every
resource for processing the new
mammalian systems it aspirin is known to
all of you because it's the mode of
action of aspirin or us is to prevent
biosynthesis of this oxalates by binding
to cycle oxygenases and inhibiting
activity of lipoxygenase and the result
of that is down regulation of some of
this absolutely so and i will show you
some of the data showing that when you
know how assembly oxygenated genes in
maize and all of a sudden instead of
increased susceptibility to pathogens
they displays don't increased resistance
so you should think of them as or that
effect as effective of salicylic acid or
aspirin winding to inhibit a dispenser
so sometimes overproduction of this
molecules lead to array of physiological
disorders so this pathway is so well
understood in mammalian systems sixty
percent of the drugs currently available
on the United States market target
asbestos of course not only sentences
but also transport but also to specific
perception in fact my proposal is
calculated because existing data from
this science paper into sultan monte
calculated what is current number of
drugs in regulating specimen and here is
estimated 85 of fda-approved drugs
target dispensaries in mammalian system
so that's how much you know more than
mammals so what do we know about plants
Lance produced a bunch of this of
Sullivan's and they reduce
remember by the oxygen is passing so
what I've oxygenators do is oxidized
fatty acid to different positions 9 or
szczecin and it's very important that
you discern these two types of the gods
it is because only 13 lipoxygenase is
capable of producing eventually just one
just one in case it lineups lipids can
not take part in ox alypium in interest
more negated by sentences they produce
what we call line of some intensity so
that reaction seems to be simple only
for different products that producer
your brother Bob seaman's yet the
problem is the box is the best day and
the complexity comes when you take into
account that this primary results by the
probe straight asses are converted by
seven different sub branches of the vote
Spencer to produce tons of different of
celebrites right and some of the
superiors right I talk to you a poisoner
who knows best of slipping field in the
plants I ask you one passion so you know
how many ox11 spread plants produce
collectively because we measured then in
many different species he is to make it
six hundred and now people this is
probably more 27 hundreds of solutions
and every year there is about four to
six reports of a new clip is being
investigated in plants so the best
understood absolutely implants of course
is just more negates it is produced by
that Allen oxide synthases branch of the
pathway and involves also fight to the
innovator in the cases only few of them
not all of them to make just more
negation and eventual just one against
our sewers now you can measure most
districts olivion's in my lab imagine
about 75 different or two living species
and then it's because we
we purchase this liquid
chromatography-mass spectrometry
instrument we are not capable of
measuring unfortunately all 700 of them
I wish we could but we want to measure
what we can get standards water so my
long term goal of my lab is to design a
function so wats lipids in maize and
whatever those functions are we are
after what they specifically limits are
doing for plant responses to stress
including a buyer expects so and the way
we do it is to generate hospital
insertional mutants in the oil contains
of those living voice synthesis pathway
if those jeans are known and so it means
there are certain lipoxygenase genes are
quite illegal sites in tight jeans there
are eight occupied today United
reductases and there are two
hydroperoxide lasers of course in RB
Dodson these numbers are about half of
that for each of these defendants and so
the way we generate these mutants is by
taking advantage of that so-called tried
to shield the system for corn available
at pioneer because that's where it
worked as opposed up and so pioneer has
paid long time ago couple dozen years
ago did this huge population about
48,000 pleasant each one in fish
yourself that was produced by the
crossing and new at Japan increase
diversity in brake lines so that
resulted in this collage mutagenized
population basically and what they do it
pioneer is
you specific primers and potato specific
primers cleaning pools of this plant I
don't actually know how many plants are
in that pool and they identify plants or
pools and individual plants and
individual families that containing
insertion of the gene in your insertion
your chain of interest so it takes about
two to three weeks Bob feel is very good
at that and it takes my lab both sample
back crosses and about ten years and to
the three generations for graduate
students to produce near such an
opponent's it back for seven states that
are now Apple to Apple comparison and
honestly because of how long does it
take to generate is Newton's he only
published maybe five percent of the
Newton's that we have generated so it's
a great time to be in my life because
mutants are generated you just come in
the lab for graduation and do the
research ok so my genome contains
sixteen lipoxygenase 'as they can be
grouped grouped roughly into large to
large subgroups this our city
lipoxygenase and those jeans are
required for just more negated by a
synthesis or relatable purpose in this
is my personal belief that all these
regions are producing gops but in
different organs I will book today only
both walks 10 and book seven eight and
nine are likely to be involved in Jade
biosynthesis besides two teen boxes they
mention our encodes a 69 lip oxygen is
one of each is very unique to mana codes
call it looks well and i will show you
data for this gene this gene somehow Oh
regulates biosynthesis of just motivated
by this type of such this is a huge
potential for crossroad between the nine
boxes versus it evolves
so this is unusual lipoxygenase it
doesn't even use fatty as it is a
substrate it uses hydroperoxide of areas
which is produced by another
lipoxygenase and what it does it please
or fatty acid into unusual effect CA
chien and c5 and could see five main if
you've not heard of Antonov so this lot
size of one is likely to be involved
specifically in biosynthesis of this
volatile fentanyl so today I will so we
generated mittens for all that matter
what fun or whatever reason we tried
many times to identify putative
insertion in different places in Cold
Spring Harbor in pioneer the premiere
came and we all this fail to identify
insertion of a mutator in lots of energy
so it's only one that for us to go
octave and I will talk today about the
phenotypes and a bunch of the function
of the end block three looks fine and
look stand and look strap alright if you
want to know about any other the
partition is that I can talk to you
personally some of them like looks too
and Vaughn are involved in salt stress
tolerance and drama tolerance looks for
appear to be required for defense
against anthropos sleep like a stalker
but they will not mention well that
looks why Sheree ninety percent identity
to look for as complete opposite
functions resistance against me sex and
in fact when you look out that gene this
plant are more resistant or the children
and oak stan is involved in in difficult
or biosynthesis okay so somehow
insertion of potato elements results in
unstable are they that gets decree so we
rarely see any
the trans confusing northern part or RNA
signal if insertions happen to be in its
own the genes so let me tell you what we
have found so far for the function of
the car situation to be an amazing
tractions alien pretty ladies and
aspergillus lives so Astrid Osiris
produces important carcinogen in fact
aflatoxin is number one the most potent
carcinogen produced by naturally by
microbes okay its most potent carcinogen
so it's it causes cancer development in
liver it's a mutagen and it also
pinnacles immunosuppression in handles
so if you said in British Lloyd's
produces another mic the box can hold
few Morrison and she wants induces or
consult as inhibits a single lipid by
synthesis in fact that's how program
cell death is used by three models
invite their binding to ceramide
synthase and preventing suva lipid
synthesis in accumulation of the cursor
sort of single limits and so the idea
about lipoxygenase is having a something
to do with the regulation of mica toxin
production came from nancy kelly
research where she showed when she
disrupts and of slipping by synthesis
genes in juice they called sifang
co-producing oxygenated this arc length
by nancy SP BOS lipoxygenase are also
producing there is one leap oxygenases
various flavors
produces an other subset of excellence
and this side factors when you know them
out they were shown to either inhibit or
promotes for Genesis depending on what
sports are regulated sexual or asexual
and they are put and regulates like
regulators mycotoxin biosynthesis so
when you shut down basins the sign
factors might be after study what
assistant in aspergillus nidulans for
aflatoxin is inhibited and if you and
they were also shown to be involved in
quorum sensing danger so if you look at
the chemical structure of plenty right
and humble direct observations you can
clearly see the resemblance okay and
that's suggested that is potentially a
lipid mediated coastal so the absolute
is produced by the fungal species can be
perceived by the plant to modulate a
limited metabolism in the plant and
plant direct box elements may affect the
physical processes of the pharmacy we
have published in Newport rating 2011
schedule is very complex to show their
schemes from baby booties really hairy
on detail so let me tell you what we
found so far towards testing that
hypothesis that absolutely is produced
by the planet may in fact have two
different effects of mitosis or if I
think induced micro toxin synthesis by
the fungus or suppress my clubs and
synthesis so in this particular case
when you know how it looks three what we
had we have seen right away when his
team seed in production growth
see if we found that ninth agency is
produced from Lee Nolin decades linoleic
acid and 90 youjizz were reduced and 98
UT it's an obsidian derivative from
linoleic acid is completely gone in this
luxury for mutant alright so they are
good line of silicon deficient so what
three is not involved in just more
negation directly cannot be it's my lip
oxygenates so when we tested how the
fungi grow on the seat is very Buddhist
we found no difference whatsoever so
fans I don't care in terms of vegetation
pros they don't care about the presence
of locks sweet gene in the course but
big surprise came when we measured
humans in b1 see all of a sudden the
mutant when fungus is wrong or Lotus
erosion they produce about 200 a full
last mycotoxin what they suggest that
looks Li is required for induction of my
detox and biosynthesis you do not ignore
it even now how it works but that is a
fact that's what the luxury function is
also without log 3 in the course the
facilities we use a lot less spores so
for that reason we placed on three at
specifically regulating secondary
metabolism and microphones and synthesis
and positively regulating where the
fungus ends for genesis so and it
appears to have no role in vegetative
roads with it fungus only in the
Colonel's so when we tested what it is
in laxmi mutants that may be responsible
for such effect in P monster so we can
ran microarray analysis long time ago is
then ground of study and bigger see that
many other day partition is such as
about six books 9 10 11 and appear 78
you are in go to jail by scientists are
all over expressed in this Locksley see
colonized by she say so you have tested
independently some of the scenes for
user-generated Newtons and we should be
what I saw that book sleep also
overexpressed looks 10 and looks wife
then suggests it looks three SunPower
nine Olympic sprinters by Lopes three
suppress expression both these are the
lipoxygenase and I will tell you about
the phenotypes of dis mutants in this
post of fusarium and aspergillus legs
and later on we'll come back to the same
gene to show you how overexpression of
these two genes in the rules impact
interaction respect to her mentor ok so
when we testicles five minutes remember
looks remittance a colonized equally
well reported on drone and either
wild-type or the mutant if you do
subscribe it's clear that was five
million see it's much more susceptible
to physically see Louise and probably
corresponding to the increased by a
massive loads by mutants we see also
increased number of cornelia produced
but what was shocking to discover that
it had not no effect whatsoever on few
Manas embody synthesis so that place
looks wide as regulated by regulating
vegetative growth and probably due to
confuse educated rules increase Canady
Asians so looks like as specific effect
productive talks like a specific effect
on the vegetative growth of the promise
logs Daniel came contrast to the log
three movements books 10 meters are
heavily colonized by the fungus and in
this case it's humanism that was
increased the public responds well to
his own growth and comedian Rosen is but
not the strongest
suggestions look Stan has more specific
effect on few months in their synthesis
unlike absolute looks like because the
phenotypes of Fox 5 meters in 10 in
terms of colonization are set so that
places look stand together it looks wide
as controlling vegetative growth books
10 potential against most stronger
effect or inducing mycotoxin synthesis
so this differently passages we have
just finished a rating just published a
little audible puppeteers will be have
found that looks 12 again another night
like oxygenase monitored specifically
oxygen is no lo dico to contain this
gene has a very specific attack on on
defense against various Hillary's Wyatt
just warning acid regulation so let me
show what the console expelled is here
so it's not as it involved but not be
involved in jail by synthesis so looks
well Milton similar between five and ten
is also heavily colon infection saying
and in this case if they introduce a lot
more of those spores and few models in
view on probably what the function of
books 12 the right absolutement is to
regulate and vegetative growth so how
does looks 12 okay early papers we were
not able to met up with his house sells
you know that so we had to send his
hands to Germans but now we can do that
analysis so we did a lot greater
analysis of syllables produced right by
this mutant and so in addition to see it
looks when minutes are a lot more
susceptible in Mexico toes to fusarium
organization and so when we measured up
syllables we found that several of the
line of slippers purchase even some
szczecin are absolutely 15
she not statistically significant though
but mine kg is specifically reduced in
the box 12 moon just that this morning
maybe the one involved in resistance in
providing assistance against the
Tsarevich eluates so when we tested this
morning education loosened levels would
be the found that in the world that it
can see if you're not inoculated by
fusarium just mana casing is increased
dramatically however not in box 12
mutants so somehow it is nine blocks and
potentially 9kg regulates just more
negated biosynthesis so the question was
there so it's really debated just like
that suggesting control and then three
we're say well since you have
republished just j division Newton see
hope your seven eight double mutants why
not test the role of just folic acid in
resistance to freeze any resource which
was a very valid question except that
looks 12 mutants are so susceptible to
various facilities that every time we
planted in the field it doesn't
germinate well because it's homes to
representing and potentially other soil
borne pathogens it's extremely
susceptible it took us one year to quite
as this mutant to grow it in such a way
that it doesn't have any fusarium
recolonize plants so but you are able to
do it when we tested a diffusion mutants
as well by the way they're also i will
show you this data they are not able to
survive on this view conditions due to
extreme susceptibility to beijing so
what we test it is this of your 78 w
infants you have to knock out both of
these genes in order to get rid of your
activity that is required from from for
converting sis vga the natural substrate
for j bias
it's into just morning is this father of
yours and six of them don't know what
they're doing we do not know what they
produce because they use Cesar PDA as a
substrate and convert it into some
profit yet unidentified unknown
absolutely potential it's with instances
in all five even talk simplification of
the beauty unsaturated carbonyl so when
we tested those mutants for resistance
against you saying it was really
shocking so we infected the plans before
we left work it poach six or seven you
come in the morning at eight o'clock and
they already macerated two days later
they just completely collapse so that
suggests that just mana case is clearly
required for defense against desire it's
Louise no doubt about that so guess that
potentially people who work with
deserving salut ages and as the jewel
slave still are you we don't be are not
confident what these the lifestyles of
these two passages are so we still argue
whether they are neck across any white
rose or not documented by toast but we
do not know if they hang but crossover
or negative so it's a chest because the
requirement of G of defense against this
pathogen that fazaia which solaris is
likely to be either an actor probe or
please the chemical and roll okay Oh
beyond seven eight new double mutants
you took my book to generate his double
mutants about two years because he would
plant a large field of segregating one
in 16 population and none of the plans
that he didn't play for double minutes
instead of I mean talking to me he says
we failed so next year he plans instead
of 200 individuals he plans five solve
an event his cleans them all and none of
them are double defense and then I don't
you cannot fail two years in the room
what happened it says well I don't know
what happened but there is no no double
mutant said well you were supposed to
think well that might mean of course
what that means that this plant there
are Alyssa so they died for some reason
and sure enough you can only guess oh
damn thing off sorry thank you so much
and dumpy off seems appropriate to so I
guess we did identify that the culprit
in this case was pleased him at least
the sperm invest what we saw in Texas
fields will the tiny or commercials also
also have pity and so it dries really
fast if you terminate the plants in
style soil and then transplant them in
the field like this and I don't even
know why he didn't work because i know
they died from fishing but he want you
to see how fast i said okay various
whatever it is he was excited about it
and look how fast they prompted
infection takes all about 10 days to
kill hundred percent of these plants so
they explain this acceptable so what was
really surprising when you started
testing for existence against us produce
things and also thoughts because that's
what Texas farmers careful they don't
care what you say believes our problem
is our thoughts and that's when I lost
funding because Locksley mutant that was
characterized by extremely low level of
contamination perfume arneson are
extremely susceptible to aspergillus lay
beside the colonel acid is raising the
field basalt they produce all this a
much greater level of aflatoxin so few
months in town of a toxin is not
colonization percolating is down there
is no change flavors just love this so
the desk there is other boxes that are
test in loxley mutants and Sheree not be
so exact opposite so in contrast of
screen opens looks fine movements were
contaminated by foot dachshund about
fivefold Max and in epigenetic
background that we have tests including
that check the breeders used for
resistance to also tops so it's really
amazing effect we danced it looks tan
and it was the same so the sick since
2007 weekend every year retention we
still being published because I don't
stand how it works because I wanted to
get the Matthews but we showed that
long-standing Europeans are there barely
cool about his body produces a whiskey
Colonel can see and think whatever's for
Jules in fact produces very little
aflatoxin so these two genes appear to
be helping the pathogen to colonize
helping the pathogen to reduce megabucks
so in case of hooks while I still do not
cannot pinpoint what exactly it produces
in terms of what of slipping it reduces
however I do know for sure that looks
tan is the sole lipoxygenase in the
National is possible for Greenlee too
volatile voice synthesis when you go to
leave a while type you see a spike in
the emission from this world because it
is the external d3x and all external
acetate all of them go up but you cannot
identify any traces of this halitosis
about 10 Newtons suggestion box tank is
the only gene required for govt I wonder
now where the jail if had anything to do
is making plans susceptible to schedule
slaves and to contamination is slaves
so let me switch gears and tell you what
we have found for some of these mutants
in terms of the interaction with
beneficial microorganisms yeah so you
can publish a paper before this vintage
I was invited to publish a paper or
long-distance igloo route to shoot okay
it's some projects it died long time ago
in 2007 and program and I never figured
out why Locksley mutants are more
existent in to enter possibly apply it
seldom to live like and they will show
you this data so if you plan to
experience in the field they have always
searched on the same team title they're
much more resistant to solving leaf
blight they are more resistant to enter
closely employed they are more resistant
to enter co-star crowd of Zion Brazilian
stork wrote and what was really
surprising that when we tested
expression of these genes in response to
fungal infection to all the leaves in in
this cases the conductive amigos the
same is true for bubbles and restaurants
this gene is not induced it doesn't want
it doesn't matter how long you imagine
expression of this gene after infection
this gene is not expressed in the play
in the place where it has effect right
the leaves are resistant to this pasture
so you would suspect that at least it
has to be expressed some house lit
during infection it's not it's not a
gene that is expressed in leaves period
where it's expected it's expressed in
news that pointed to as potential
significance of food expression of these
genes or on what is happening in the
above ground pools in terms of
resistance
increase resistance so the hypothesis
then walls o'clock three militants
produce some signal in the rules that
are consorted from the roots into the
lesions in stocks and induced increased
resistance so how to test of course if
you've worked with dye pots you know
what to do in this case okay three
minutes ago well that you would you will
do the crafting experiment unfortunately
for those of you who work with monocots
it's not possible and it's a huge
problem so then we had to come up with a
new massive how to do it is theft bike
experiment so one time I both work was
cutting this plant because he was done
his end when you look at them or my
brother you're so much silence sad that
you can collect milliliters of it within
a single day and it's oh wow this that
would be a very firm you to know if
reason is taken as different present
being silent here so but how to apply
when you make a tiny incisions once
inches away from each other all these
siblings and apply twice diluted silence
and only 10 micro litre six hours before
infection and then in fact mystical
Grameen ego and what we saw is was
really interesting so when you collect
silencer from wild-type and apply to
implants they are normally infected for
equally protocol normal vision however
when you take the same plan the same
genotype and a half their vocational
valence and collected from box three
militants this plans for much more
resistant to pull the documentation
supporting the eight-year the runes of
luxury produced
the Sun signal and you can collect it
and we can bash it and apply to that
while the plants and you see this event
so then also suggested that potentially
this gene is regulated particular
appearance prognosis wounds so remember
when you get rid of locks three the
plants are more resistant in background
orders but box key is not expressly so
it's expressed in root log 3 is a
negative regulator then a very sorry and
if so then trichoderma may or may not
not have effect on this gene or the
mutant so if you treat it trichoderma a
restricted number means roots of wild at
all those three miracles and of course
in world up what you see rapid or making
uses technical assistance so the lesions
are much smaller however in the normal
actually compared a violent violet here
to convert my juices in business
business invokes limit they ready
resistant doesn't matter how much like
the derma they have on the roots they
already resistant to take a turn so then
because of this was in order protected
or much to have and I oh sorry amusing
activity it must suppress locks free
expression endurance and hope valley
it's easy to propose this hey boss I
remember like now and they weren't doing
my students were doing this experiment I
thought oh my god what if it's not going
to work I will never be able to submit
this paper and I was shocked how
beautiful it work so then and what we
did it we used a delta s amount of
liquid or without this small peptide
it's a sweet pad line when you know
about that gene for sm one these plants
are not able to induce secure smokeout
movements they were not able to reduce
systemic resistance in the leaves when
you overexpress there is worse more so
this SF on seed protein is required for
induced
systemic resistance easily so we use
this mutant and prepare it to the effect
of expectation vs. wild type on
expression for three nodes and what we
saw that while that indeed like I really
hoped it would happen and what the
hypothermic effects roots books read
expression is repressed however looks we
cannot be repressed when you use this is
artificial movers so that places look
sweet as one of the targets for sm 11
function of sm one fumble energy and
from the protein is the suppress
expression for floats the stream then
the question was what it is it looks
with makes it so crazy that you could
use this is our signal all the time so
we can test expression of all all the
lipoxygenase from each week a mutant or
some other genes and what we saw is
incredible so if you look at nine
lipoxygenase pressure in the roots
compared to welcome there is 420 full
induction overexpression of logs for in
the log three minutes as it looks fibers
of Express looks available to express
and bunch of other look at this HTC sir
james or or hope you are they for
example 22 424 424 Alan oxide cyclist
who r e8 for overexpression interviews
so the roots of look-see overexpressed
whole bunch of this pod of silicon
biosynthesis and ethical investment
decisions he suggested just one occasion
nine ox lipids and actually maybe the
reason why this mutants are more
resistant to fully investigate and that
signal is produced in books
units Constitution rather it then in
inducible man so we tested it doesn't
look Stan just because we knew exactly
what is with it is doing in terms of
their chemistry is required for gob by
sentences but also because we found
something really unique about dog stand
behind a project to localize sub seldom
variables NP is in Compton cell so we
used on Jenny plants is a help of Dave
Jackson from cosmic carbon and he they
produce Jenny plant that express quietly
type of Stan and they look everywhere
one looks them ears and found that book
stand spawning be found this was founded
for a blessed and they also identify
some other organelles still do not know
where what it is but what was really
surprised intercedes will expand seems
to stream in BOS florin in silent
because if it moves with opposite
directions so extend directly as a
protein secreted in 24 mins I'm so that
may look stand a perfect candidate to be
relevant to long-distance signaling
right so when then we test book ten
Milton's 44 I saw in response to prep
adorable musician so when you in fact
and you have wild that you think you see
in this case is out regular they are
normally susceptible the addition of
trichoderma to the roots makes it more
resistant for the total protection looks
10 Newtons arbitrate surprising this
gops are believed to be required for
defense against pathogens we did not see
in fact his mutants were more resistant
not only in the leaf looks 10 mutants
were resistant is a strength to get
accosted by two
the so-called Azalea stop we were
resistant to everything we tested but
immediately after you treat box Daniels
mr. could learn this plants become all
of sudden completely susceptible to
attributed to call each other
communication not only they have both
induced systemic resistance eight league
in some interesting phenotype I quality
juice systemic susceptibility because
remember these plans are resistant
result regularly however they are a lot
more susceptible than regular beads
around so that suggestion box 10 is
relevant to eat and we tested all the
mutants in that list and at least before
exactly the same time for a box 12
mutation so look scrawny opens are
normally they there is no change in the
resistance levels but one plant is cole
mize with epidermal they become a lot
more society so here now funded by used
a to identify his own business signals
in theory utilizing to silent said that
we can collect collect massively
profiling ox Olympians hormones and
other metabolites if you already have
several candidates needs to be tested
and those candidates are whether they
are not just mana cases it's totally
against the grain because just mana case
it is believed to be required for virus
are in tight let's be she's not in men's
when we used a pair seven eight JD few
minutes they are still capable of
responding to check the door
mobilization by increased resistance in
the stem and in the leaf so J is not the
long-distance thing is some other [ __ ]
movement produced by nine up oxygenases
or precursors oj that are required for
induces
so then I would like to invite your
questions this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu